The goal of a basketball team
is similar to that of a baseball
team, making the playoffs.
So how many games
does a team need
to win in order to
make the playoffs?
Recall that in the lecture
we found this number
by looking at a graph.
Here in R, let's use
the table command
to figure this out for the NBA.
So that's just
table(NBA$W, NBA$Playoffs).
So our table pops up.
Let's scroll to the top
so we see what's going on.
OK so as we typed in, we've
got the number of wins
here as the rows.
And 0 if a team didn't make
the playoffs, 1 if a team did
make the playoffs
in the columns.
So for all of our
data, for example,
consider all the times
that a team won 17 games.
So this happened
11 times in total.
And all 11 times the teams
didn't make it to the playoffs
when they won 17 games.
Let's scroll down and look
at a much higher number
for contrast.
For example, 61 wins.
If a team 61 games then 10
of those times they made it
to the playoffs, and
0 times they didn't.
So it seems like
if you win 61 games
you are definitely going
to make it to the playoffs.
But I'm sure we can find
a much better threshold.
Let's take a look at the table,
say around the middle section.
OK, so here we can
see that a team who
wins say about 35 games
or fewer almost never
makes it to the playoffs.
We see a lot of 0s and 1s
in this column up until 35.
After 35 we start seeing
some numbers over here.
So teams are starting to
make it to the playoffs.
And if we scroll down, we
see that after about 45 wins,
teams almost always
make it to the playoffs.
We see very few 1s and 0s in
the category of not making it.
So it seems like
a good goal would
be to try to win about 42 games.
If a team can win
about 42 games then
they have a very good chance
of making it to the playoffs.
So in basketball, games are
won by scoring more points
than the other team.
Can we use the difference
between points scored
and points allowed throughout
the regular season in order
to predict the number of
games that a team will win?
Let's give it a try.
First we add a variable that is
the difference between points
scored and points allowed.
Let's call this NBA$PTSdiff.
And that's just the difference
between points scored,
which is points, and
points allowed, which
is opponent's points.
All right, so we've
created a variable.
Let's first make a
scatter plot to see
if it looks like there's
a linear relationship
between the number of
wins that a team wins
and the point difference.
So this is easy to do just
with the Plot command.
NBA$PTSdiff and NBA$W.
So our graph pops
up and it looks
like there's an incredibly
strong linear relationship
between these two variables.
So it seems like
linear regression
is going to be a good way
to predict how many wins
a team will have given
the point difference.
Let's try to verify this.
So we're going to
have points diff
as our independent
variable in our regression,
and W for wins as the
dependent variable.
So let's call this WinsReg.
And we just use the lm command
as before progressing w
on the points diff and
using the NBA data.
All right, so we've
created our regression.
Let's take a look
at the summary.
OK, so the first
thing that we notice
is that we've got very
significant variables
over here.
And an R squared of
0.9423, which is very high.
And this is verifying
the scatter plot
we saw before that there's a
very strong linear relationship
between the wins and
the points difference.
So let's write
down the regression
equation that we found.
We see that the number of
wins, W, is equal to 41.
That's coming from the
coefficient estimate
for the intercept.
Plus 0.0326*PTSdiff.
And that 0.0326 is coming
from the coefficient estimate
for points difference.
So we saw earlier with
the table that a team
would want to win
about at least 42 games
in order to have a good chance
of making it to the playoffs.
So what does this mean in terms
of their points difference?
Well, we can calculate it.
If we want this to be
greater than or equal to 42,
that means that the
points difference
would need to be greater
than or equal to 42 minus 41
divided by 0.0326.
So if we actually
do that calculation,
we see that this
is equal to 30.67.
So we need to score at
least 31 more points
than we allow in order
to win at least 42 games.